tus casas han sido incendiadas su ganado
robado algunos de estos evacuados Fueron
perseguidos por turbas de casi 2.000
personas y obligados a esconderse en la
jungla durante días cuando detallaron
los enfrentamientos entre las tribus
Cookie naga y la comunidad maytei grupos
étnicos de la India
todo se quemó Entonces no tenemos lugar
para quedarnos allí dado que no tenemos
nuestras casas
quemaron todo 92 casas para ser exactos
y ya no nos atrevemos a quedarnos allí
de nuevo sin ningún tipo de protección
del gobierno estamos desprotegidos
Perdón perdón
los enfrentamientos comenzaron el pasado
4 de mayo después de que la tribu Cookie
protestara en contra de la comunidad
maitei que constituye más de El 50% de
la población del estado de manipur en el
noreste del país mediante el estatus de
tribu registrada el estado brinda
protección y privilegios a los grupos
más marginados de la India como trabajos
gubernamentales y educación subsidiada
un reconocimiento solicitado por los
maytei las tribus naga y Cookie que
Residen en las colinas y bosques
constituyen el 40% de la población del
estado y gozan del estado de tribu
programada dicen ser los grupos más
marginados y consideran que otorgar el
mismo reconocimiento a los maytakes
vulnera sus derechos el ejército indio
desplegó miles de tro en el estado para
restaurar el orden y evacuar a
sobrevivientes a campamentos del
ejército
y así en los últimos dos días creo que
casi 2000 personas o más es lo que hemos
evacuado A sus áreas de interés a donde
quieran ir hemos estado proporcionando
un paso seguro cookies como amateis se
realizan patrullas militares cada pocos
kilómetros y se ha emitido una orden de
abrir fuego para casos extremos de
violencia